gone are the days where every movie
around had some kind of Terra bad tie-in
video game
you know the ones where you spend half
your time fighting through bugs playing
the same dull mission over and over
again listening to the actors dying
inside while trying to figure out who
this is supposed to be
Perseus in Clash of the Titans if you
were wondering we miss those halcyon
days and we think there are some movies
that are crying out for a videogame but
don't worry we've thought this through
no janky adaptations here thank you he
has seven films that would make truly
awesome games
starting with one of the most insane but
great movies that we think would make
equally insane but great videogames
crank the premise of crank is that
British hitman Chev Chelios has been
poisoned and his heart will stop beating
unless his adrenaline keeps flowing
constantly which he does by increasingly
ridiculous means including being shot by
defibrillators getting into fights and
standing upright on a police motorcycle
with his ass in the breeze but this kind
of ludicrous scenario is something that
would be perfect in an eclectic
open-world sandbox game similar to
sunset overdrive crackdown or even the
controversial postal games imagine
playing through a dense virtual city
with a series of objectives and missions
but all the while having to manage your
adrenaline levels to keep yourself alive
drive like a maniac to get hype start
fights in the street to get that blood
flowing Rob hospitals and pharmacies of
epinephrine jump off buildings and have
planes before parachuting to the ground
you could take so many things that make
games like this exciting and instead of
having the risk of dying in game you'd
be doing it to keep your heart ticking
the idea of taking the classic action
sandbox game and turning it way up to 11
might just be stupid enough to word
in the right hands kung fu hustle could
be turned into a brilliant fighting game
and Capcom should be the developers to
do it Stephen Chows film is what you get
if you mix the slapstick or Looney Tunes
with the stunning action of Chinese
wushu movies it focuses on a ragtag
bunch of martial artists that have
over-the-top superhuman abilities a
natural fit for a 2d fighting game made
by Capcom while the movie has a funny
and heartfelt story about a downtrodden
antihero trying to find his place in the
world like this guy I need to know as
well
for what lies ahead Kung Fu Hustle would
work better as a flashy fast-paced
fighting game like this one it's the
movies cost of colorful characters that
are the real stars and they're
absolutely insane abilities will be
perfect for the hyperactive gameplay
style of Marvel vs. Capcom each
character has a distinct story visual ID
any and most importantly fighting style
there's a lecherous old landlord that
also happens to be a master of Taichi
the staff wielding baker and this insane
old toad man that can stop bullets with
his fingers there'd be a nice mix of
up-close powerhouses like foreign
assassins and projectile specialists all
of which can leap hundreds of feet into
the air and air dash around like
Roadrunner Kung Fu Hustle would give
capcom the material it needs to make a
technical one-on-one fighter in the
style of street fighter but with the
bold brash and super kinetic style of
Marvel vs. Capcom I'd also take Shaolin
Sokka in the style of Mario Strikers
charged we can't have everything 2014
oscar-winning drumming drama whiplash
might not be the first movie you think
would make a great game but hear me out
because I have had ideas imagine a
rhythm action game where you play the
drums obviously and your end goal is to
become core drummer in Fletcher's
prestigious studio band and perform at
the JVC Jazz Festival I'm thinking that
it plays out similarly to parappa the
rapper boy you've got the band around
you playing various jazz tunes and you
respond to button prompts to add your
drum parts but the crucial difference is
that instead of having nice teachers
like chop chop master onion supporting
and riffing with you you get JK Simmons
foaming at the mouth screaming at you
that it's not quite his tempo not quite
my tempo it's all good no worries here
we go
bonus point if you manage to avoid any
of the slaps or chairs that he decides
to throw your way instead of the game
telling you that you rap in good or cool
or bad or awful there's only three
grades you're on the beat you're
dragging or you're rushing there could
even be some kind of minigame where you
aggressively break up with your
girlfriend who watches as you tap your
way through one awful dialogue choice
after the other displaying nothing but
callous insensitivity it's alright
though she goes on to become Supergirl
there was a time in videogame history
where you could virtually manage pretty
much anything you've played sim sea
themed Hospital space colony but have
you ever been put in charge of an
extravagant world-famous hotel set in
between two world wars no I didn't think
so
guess I'm the old devs from bullfrog and
Maxis sit him down with Wes Anderson and
let's get started in the best simulation
game ever darling cash your mind back to
the days of theme park theme hospital
and the slew of other similar games
building a location filling it with
visitors and equipment and even solving
crises and if you're old enough to
remember those games then you're old
enough to have seen the grand Budapest
hotel picture slowly building up the
extravagant hotel from humble beginnings
to its grand pink majesty ensuring your
guests are satisfied with the services
of the eccentric hotel kept fed with
cakes from the Mendel bakery and
serviced with plenty of sponge baths
random events like snowstorms or pastry
shortages can add some variety to the
gameplay as well as scripted events like
the first world war that the hotel
survived through can become larger
challenges for the player to work
through and while you're managing the
hotel earning experience new items and
growing the grand Budapest hotel you can
move your way up from humble lobby boy -
romantic concierge
when it comes to giving people the
heebie-jeebies few movies eyes revered
as The Shining which is why it makes for
a great first-person survival horror
game The Shining secluded hotel setting
spooky supernatural happenings and
themes of losing grip on sanity make it
well-suited for an experience in the
same vein as amnesia the Dark Descent
and the ideal candidate to make a video
game adaptation of the Kubrick classic
is frictional games the team behind
amnesia and a whole bunch of other games
that have made gamers far and wide paint
their pants brown fictional
environmental storytelling shops could
create an interesting new angle on the
story allowing the player to slowly
unravel the mysteries of the Overlook
Hotel simulator amnezia sanity mechanic
things could get stranger as time goes
by and as Jack gets crazier set pieces
like the ball scene could represent
milestones in his descent into madness
and like the use of light in amnesia
alcohol could be used in a risk reward
system knocking back bobbins with Lloyd
and the ghostly gang may help jack
regain some fleeting control but I could
also loosen his grip on reality in the
long run making the weird stuff even
weirder of course it all culminates in a
full-blown meltdown where we get to see
the worst that the hotel has hiding in
its dark corners it could even have
sequences taking place from the
perspective of Danny Jack's son which
would let frictional use visions like
that bloody elevator or these creepy ass
twins alternatively how about a hack and
slash horror game think snakes nightmare
from Metal Gear Solid 3 except we've
Shelley Duvall and a knife
while there's been dread games before
and judging by actor call Urban's
cryptic tweezing there may be another on
the way
it's practically criminal the director
piece Travis's interpretation of the law
hasn't been in any video games yet
what's also criminal is that a 2012
movie doesn't have a sequel yet but
that's another impassioned plea for
another time
so in my head a drag game is a
third-person cover shooter with a gritty
aesthetic similar to Gears of War but
instead of fighting locusts you take on
thugs and drug dealers in the peach
trees tower block rookie Cassandra comes
along with you but crucially this ain't
no escort mission she acts as an AI
companion similar to Elizabeth from
BioShock Infinite
she gives you support and uses her
psychic abilities to warn you about any
enemy skulking around mama the drug lord
atop peach trees has flooded the block
with an addictive drug called slow-mo
that reduces users perception of time
which would be perfect for some Max
Payne as the bullets find sequences
basically I just want more of that dread
and I've happily spent 10 years in the
ISO cubes playing that game edge of
tomorrow live die repeat whatever you
want to call the sci-fi movie about
using your deaths to become a bear
warrior just get from software on the
video game version ASAP in the world of
edge of tomorrow humanity is getting the
snot kicked out of them by an alien race
and Tom Cruise's character bill Cage is
dragged into combat and shortly
thereafter killed swap the sci-fi saying
with dragons in an age of fire and
you've got the respawn system from Dark
Souls every time you die in Dark Souls
were expected to learn something a trap
and enemy location a move set something
to let you live that little bit longer
and progress a little bit more into the
next run through the edge of tomorrow
does pretty much that every time bill
Cage dies he learns a little more gets a
little more training memorize his ways
going to be attacked from until it's
second nature in my mind the game would
have to start brutally hard dying again
and again chipping away and growing so
slowly until you gather up some
semblance of confidence until the game
snatches it away and crushes you all
over again a formula that's frustrated
many but has been proven to work
prepare to die and live and repeat
so there's our picks for movies that
would actually make awesome games if
you've got any ideas make sure to stick
them in the comments below I'll gather
the best ones put a pitch document
together send it to some devs and you
know while we wait for the inevitable
rejection why don't you check out some
more videos just like this one here eye
games bought make sure to LIKE and
subscribe and we'll see you next time